people of the Internet's hello and
welcome to the first ever fortnight
fundamentals your one-stop shop for all
the basics of fortnight this is the
first-ever episode and a series of
videos designed to help you get started
with what is currently the hottest game
in the world we'll kick things off by
answering one simple question what is
fortnight for starters it's a video game
for pretty much every video game
platform on the planet ps4 xbox PC and
switch it's even on mobile devices it's
developed by Epic Games the same studio
behind Unreal Tournament and Gears of
War believe it or not there are actually
two modes fortnight's save the world
a paid title which has you teaming up
with friends to survive waves of zombies
and then there's fortnight battle royale
a free-to-play competitive mode where
you and up to three friends are dropped
into a world where you'll need to
scavenge weapons and items harvest
materials and build forts to help you
take out other human players all seeking
to be the last person or team standing
this video focuses on the battle royale
side of the game there are three primary
modes within fortnight battle royale
solos duo's and squads solos is you
alone against 99 other solo players
where as duo's has you teaming up with
one friend finally they're squads which
is where you and three friends team up
to take on other teams of four there are
also limited time modes which you only
have access to for a set amount of time
before epic rotates the mount for a new
mode each game plays out something like
this you and all other players are
briefly placed on spawn island where the
game loads you and other players into a
match once everyone is loaded in the
battle bus revs up and takes to the
skies the path for the battle bus is
random and you'll need to adjust your
landing zone accordingly the map is
large and you'll have plenty of choices
when deciding where to land after you
exit the bus it becomes a race to the
ground to quickly grab weapons shields
and harvest materials depending on where
you land you may find yourself in a
fight immediately or you may have a
quiet landing zone that gives you the
opportunity to loot in peace now what's
that about harvesting materials you see
what separates fortnight from other
games in the battle where Al Jean rrah
is the building component you'll have
the option to set up a base and build a
four of
or quickly build a wall and ramp in
front of you if attacked by an enemy in
order to compete with the best you'll
need to master the game's building
component I'm out right now you'll
always have your trusty pickaxe which is
used for harvesting materials that allow
you to build walls ramps floors and
roots you can use the pickaxe to attack
as well but I'd only recommend that if
you have no other option other than that
you have five slots to hold weapons and
healing items such as shields bandages
or med kits it's up to you to decide
what you want to carry fortnight
supports a variety of play styles which
means you can rush people with shotguns
or play stealth and engage from long
range with a sniper rifle I got one
there's one chasing me in solos enemies
go down immediately after you deplete
their health which can be up to 200 hit
points consisting of their base health
which is 100 points and shield which
also goes up to 100 points for a total
of 200 in duo's or squads players with
teammates still alive will become
knocked when their health is drained you
can choose to fully eliminate them from
there or find their teammate to finish
them both off if the teammate gets the
better of you however they'll then be
able to revive their fallen teammate if
they dispatch you quickly enough you see
when teammates enter the nacht state
they'll have 100 health that starts
ticking down immediately they can only
crawl on the ground and can't shoot or
run away shortly after a match begins a
white circle will appear on your map
which is the zone everyone must start
moving toward with the appearance of the
circle a storm will slowly begin moving
in making its way closer and closer to
that inner white circle a timer will be
displayed on screen letting you know
exactly how much time you have left
before the storm will reach you if you
get caught in the storm
you'll take continuous damage until you
exit or die the circle will continue
getting smaller and smaller and if need
be the circle will disappear entirely
for the final zone the shrinking of the
playable area will force everyone to
engage eventually you can only hide for
so long once you die or hopefully win
your match
everything resets and you're taken back
to the main screen and trust me you'll
want to load up for another match again
again and again you do earn points by
completing various challenges that reset
periodically some daily and some weekly
these points can earn you various skins
emotes and other cosmetic items you
don't have to spend a penny on fortnight
Battle Royale
but if you enjoy the cosmetics and trust
me you probably will you'll get the most
bang for your buck by purchasing the
Battle Pass which costs nine hundred and
fifty bucks which is the equivalent of
nine dollars and fifty cents considering
mini skins in the game cost between
fifteen and twenty dollars alone the
battle pass is a great value if you like
the cosmetics it contains and plan on
playing a lot you see buying the battle
pass alone won't unlock every skin
inside you'll need to actually play the
game in order to rank up your battle
pass during each fortnight season which
lasts about ten weeks and there you have
it folks now you know all about the
basics a fortnight Battle Royale in
upcoming videos we're gonna tackle even
more to help you better understand the
weapons at your disposal how to build
and more if you enjoyed this video and
that sounds like something of interest
to you please give it a like share with
your friends and devily consider
subscribing to my channel thanks so much
for watching good luck with your next
draw oh and one final tip you're just
starting out you probably don't want to
land until two towers your first game
[Music]